Okay, welcome back. Welcome to video
number five. In video number four, what we
looked at was the importance of
calculating your odds through
distributions. And essentially we looked
at what is historical volatility.
Historical volatility gives us a very good
idea about the opportunities in an asset
that we're about to offer.
to trade over any given time horizon. But
what's also important is also calculating
the future or expected volatility in an
asset that we're about to trade. And
retail traders don't really understand
this and don't really do anything about
it. And even professional traders, a lot
of professional traders think, and retail
traders think that if they look at implied
volatility,
when they look at it, they interpret it in
a certain way, they interpret it in an
incorrect way, if you like. You're going
to find out why this is not necessarily
the case, not true in the next section.
Because what implied volatility really is
about is two things. It's your expected
opportunities in the future, but it also
provides you with a good measure for
managing your risk.
So we're not looking at historical
volatility anymore. We're now looking at
the implied volatility of an asset, what's
going to happen in the future. Now, one of
the big problems here is retail traders
telling the market how they're going to
trade. So let's think about this for a
second. If the market that you're about to
trade or take a position in says that the
market is going to trade.
If volatility says that volatility is
going up in the next 30 days, for example,
or expected to go up, then what does that
mean? It means that the market is now
expecting that shorter term opportunities
are going to come into the market.
And the reverse is true. If implied
volatility is falling, then it means that
shorter term opportunities are expected to
come out of the market. Now, what
successful professional traders do is they
don't tell the market how they're going to
trade, like unsuccessful retail traders,
they just let the market tell them
essentially what the opportunities are
expected to be in the future.
And they adapt and they adapt and they
switch their trading style between being
short term traders and longer term
traders. Now, this is one of the main
things that I really want you to take from
this section of the video is when you when
we go to the stage, I want you to really
focus on this statement.
The statement. The statement that
volatility is a trader's best friend and a
portfolio manager's worst enemy, because
that's got a lot to do with opportunities
and risk management. So as in
opportunities over the short, medium and
longer term, and also managing your risk
over the short, medium and longer term.
Because professional traders switch
between being short term traders to medium
and longer term traders dependent on the
messages coming from the implied
volatility in the market. So please focus
on that statement when we cut to the
stage. Volatility is a trader's best
friend and a portfolio manager's worst
enemy.
What we're then going to move on to after
we cut back to the office, we're then
going to move on to video six where Chris
is going to show you how to calculate your
own volatility index for any asset. So you
can then use the historical volatility
measures that you've already learned and
add onto it the implied volatility
measures that Chris is going to teach you
in video number six.
Okay, so let's go to the stage and I'll
see you for a summary after that section.
So now we're going to concentrate a bit
more on volatility. Volatility is really
important to a professional trader. The
asset, the volatility profile of the asset
dictates what your opportunities are, not
the other way around. You don't tell the
volatility.
Not the other way around. You don't tell
the market how much you're going to make
today. The market tells you. Has anybody
heard of this S&P 500 volatility index?
Does anybody want to explain what it is?
Based on the option prices?
Correct, yeah. But what does it actually
tell us?
Implied volatility.
Yeah, implied volatility. What we looked
at before was historical volatility. What
we're looking at now is implied
volatility. It's forward looking by 30
days and it comes out as an annualized
number. So it's the volatility that
options traders are implying through the
prices that they're making in S&P 500
options.
It's the volatility. It's the volatility
implied for the next 30 days, then
annualized. What happens when they expect
more volatility?
They raise their prices for options
because they don't want to be short
volatility at a low price.
What happens if they expect volatility to
go down? The opposite. Options become
cheaper.
But this is really important. The VIX in
itself is really important.
Because volatility on a short term basis
or over any time horizon is essentially a
trader's best friend.
Because if you have it over any time
horizon, you have opportunities.
So being able to predict volatility is
essential.
Why? Because on the flip side, volatility
is a professional trader's worst
nightmare.
A portfolio manager's worst nightmare.
Sorry.
So you're basically, as a trader, you're a
slave to volatility.
We looked at the historical volatility.
That's the beast. That's how it behaves.
The implied volatility is how we expect
the beast to behave in the next 30 days on
an annualized basis.
Make sense?
So when volatility, implied, goes up and
it goes up very quickly, what happens?
What happens to a professional trader's
approach?
It changes.
Because on 80% of days on the historical
volatility profile of the S&P 500, the
biggest stock market in the world, nothing
happens.
So what's the approach of a professional
trader 80% of the time?
It's actually to run and maintain
portfolios with a one to three month time
horizon.
But then, when things happen, volatility
goes up.
Expected or implied volatility goes up.
So what does a professional trader do?
Well, they have to switch from being a
portfolio manager very quickly to being a
short term trader.
And this has hidden consequences that
people don't really have appreciation for.
We're going to go through an example now.
Just a small portfolio.
One million dollar gross exposure.
That's a big retail trader portfolio, but
it's a tiny bank or hedge fund portfolio.
And let's make a few assumptions about
this one million dollar portfolio.
So we've got a gross exposure of a million
dollars.
And we're just going to assume that all of
the exposure is cash for cash.
So we've got the long value of the
portfolio is 500,000.
And the short value is 500,000.
And all the positions are $50,000, i.e. 5%
position sizes.
What do we know about this portfolio if
it's an S&P 500 portfolio long and short?
Well, from the historical volatility
profile,
the market moves up and down 35 basis
points on a normal day.
On average, yeah?
So on average, if you just did nothing,
80% of the time,
you'd make or lose $3,500.
Make sense?
That's the volatility of your S&P 500
portfolio.
But what happens if S&P 500 volatility is
expected to double in the next 30 days?
Well, very clearly, you're expecting that
your profit or loss volatility on a
one-day basis is going to double.
So what happens?
Well, that million dollars is not a
million dollars anymore.
It's two million dollars.
So without you ever doing anything, if
volatility doubles and you've got a
typical S&P 500 long short portfolio,
if volatility doubles and you do nothing,
you've taken more risk.
Does that make sense?
So what do you think happens at a Goldman
Sachs morning meeting when all the traders
go into a meeting room at 7am?
And they've got a billion dollars of
exposure on the desk, long short.
And the head of derivatives says
volatility is creeping and we're expecting
it to go up into next week's non-farm
payrolls.
What do you think happens?
What's the message from the boss?
No, the opposite.
They're taking more risk without actually
doing anything.
If you hedge, your gross exposure goes up.
So what's the message from the top?
Reduce your exposure.
Cut your exposure in half.
Get rid of all the positions that you
don't really want.
And the positions that you want to have,
just trade out of half the position size.
So if you've got a $30 million position
long in XYZ, and your view is that it's
going up forever, it doesn't really
matter.
Because now the risk on XYZ, when
volatility in the market doubles, is
double, without you doing anything.
And what happens when they switch?
Well, what do you receive when you trade
out of positions?
You reduce your risk, but what do you
actually receive physically?
Cash.
Or in a trading account, a retail trader
account, you'll receive available margin.
So you free up margin in your account.
Yeah?
So what does that mean?
If volatility starts moving, and it starts
going up, and you've reduced your exposure
overall, you now have a higher cash
exposure in your account than before.
What do you then go and do with that cash?
You're being told a very strong message.
You start trading short term.
Because now, you're being told by the
beast, hello Mr. Trader, I've decided to
wake up.
Why don't you go and hunt somewhere else?
Sorry?
What, go to a different jungle?
Yeah, of course.
You can do.
You're using the biggest stock market in
the world as the example.
Of course you can.
So if you want to, you know, the processes
here are the most important thing, because
if I show you this stuff for the world's
biggest stock market, I'll give you
step-by-step guides on how to do it, and
you understand the thought process, then
you can take all the spreadsheets and
start hunting around for other stuff.
That's your job, not mine.
I'm not here to spoon-feed you.
As we discussed right at the beginning.
You've got to have the self-starter
mentality, which you've got, because the
first question you ask is, well, Anton, if
I take that spreadsheet, can I just go
hunting for volatility?
Of course you can.
That's what I'm giving it to you for.
So you've got to do it yourself.
So when you see the VIX go up, what you're
actually looking at, the implied
volatility for the next 30 days, what
you're actually looking at in that number
is for every unit it goes up, another unit
of risk has been added to everyone's
portfolio in the world.
And at some point, if it keeps going up,
there's going to have to be risk
reduction.
Now that doesn't necessarily mean that the
market goes down.
Because implied volatility for the VIX is
implied volatility up or down for the next
30 days.
A lot of people forget that.
So what you have to try and do as a trader
is to run portfolios based on, and you do
that based on historical volatility
evidence.
With one to three month time horizons.
And this is what all professional traders
do at investment banks in their prop
function.
And at hedge funds.
They do it for a reason.
And this is the reason.
And then when volatility goes up, you have
to switch.
You switch from being a portfolio manager
to an animal trader.
And the transition process is simply a
period where you raise cash.
Because the cash then enables you to take
advantage of the short term opportunities.
If you don't do anything, your risk, if
volatility goes up by 100%, your risk
doubles without you doing anything.
And then you're the rabbit in the
headlights who will trade out of
everything at the bottom.
Providing liquidity for the guys who
actually saw it coming.
And who transitioned and did something to
raise cash.
And if you raise cash, you then have the
right to short term trade.
You do not have the right to short term
trade if your risk has just doubled
without you doing anything.
And you've got a little bit of cash
available, so you're trying to make your
losses back by punting.
You only get the right to trade short term
if you reduce your risk.
And you'll see this happen over and over
and over again at investment banks and
hedge funds.
Where a guy gets caught in the headlights,
gets called into a room.
The boss actually has to trade out of the
position for him.
Because that guy is now frozen and he
doesn't know what to do.
And then he's either told to go home or
sit on the desk and ignore what's going on
in the market.
Because he's not allowed to day trade.
But this is the first thing you learn when
you start learning to become a
professional trader.
This will be your first year in practice
at an investment bank or a hedge fund.
Being a portfolio manager and switching.
And this is why I never make the claim
that trading can be taught in one weekend
or in one day.
It simply can't because you have to
experience this to really understand it.
The way you should look at the volatility
index really is a very simple traffic
light system.
Where if the VIX goes up by a certain
amount.
And by the way there's no rule book.
You literally cannot go to WH Smiths,
Waterstones or Blackwells and buy a book.
When to buy and sell volatility.
It's totally subjective.
And it's all subjective to the risk that
you have yourself.
This is just a back of the envelope
situation.
Where over time, over many, many years.
If you stick to this idea and this
process.
You should be fine.
If it goes up by 25%, what's happened?
The risk of every portfolio in the world
has gone up by 25%.
You must be doing something.
If you don't do anything, you're the
rabbit in the headlights.
So you've got to do something.
So you transition.
And you enter the day trading zone.
Because you're allowed.
Why?
Because you've raised cash.
And you've been proactive.
So this is by no means a hard and fast
rule.
So don't think this is a rule book.
There are no rules.
It's subjective to your own risk.
Yeah?
But this should stand you in good stead
over your lifetime.
If you're trading in the world's biggest
stock market.
Yeah?
If it's in transition and rising.
And what do we mean by that?
If the VIX itself has moved 25%.
Yeah?
Roughly speaking.
Just reduce everything in your portfolio
by 50%.
Or get rid of half the positions in your
portfolio that you don't really want.
How do you get to that stage?
Well, just rank them.
If you've got 20 positions, rank them from
1 to 20, favourite to least favourite.
It's not hard.
I'd get rid of the bottom 10.
When it's in transition and falling,
portfolio risk in the world is going down.
So what are you being told?
You're being told by the beast.
Hey, Mr. Trader.
It's now less risky to own a portfolio.
So you start putting cash to work.
You want to get invested in a portfolio,
long short, into your favourite ideas.
Fixed within your own risk management
parameters.
So just double the size of all your
remaining positions.
And stop day trading.
That's what you've got to do.
You'll be told this message because you'll
see volatility going down.
And you'll start losing money day trading.
It'll become more difficult.
And that's why on the very first slide.
When we said, who is this course not for?
It's for people who never take a message
from their losses.
When you start losing money day trading,
you take the message that day trading
opportunities are now no longer available.
So you build a portfolio.
And you can get loads and loads of
exposure on in the comfort and knowledge
that the market's not going to move
adversely overnight and completely wipe me
out.
Because now the market is expecting no
volatility in the world.
Make sense?
So there are no hard and fast rules
telling you exactly what to do in your
portfolio.
But that should stand you in good stead.
Second caveat here.
People must have heard this before.
The VIX is often called the fear index.
But don't mistake it for a situation where
the market has to go down.
So if fear in the world is rising, the
market must go down.
It doesn't necessarily mean that.
In 2003, the VIX went through the roof and
that was the beginning of the bull market.
Because everyone was expecting a bad world
in the next 12 months.
So everyone was short.
And what happened?
Everything came out positive.
Consecutively.
And the VIX actually went up because
people feared losing money in their
portfolio.
being net short.
Make sense?
By definition, the VIX is an annualized
volatility number.
Calculated for the next 30 days.
For the market going up or down.
Probably a good thing to do is just no
longer call it the fear index.
If you're going to call it the fear index,
it's the fear of being wrong either way.
So what do people ask most about the VIX?
Well, if there's the one on the S&P 500,
is there one available for others?
Of course there is.
It's all publicly available information.
On the Eurostox 600, you've got the
V-Stocks.
You've got the V-Footsie, V-DAX.
You've got a volatility index publicly
available on decent websites like Yahoo
Finance, MarketWatch.com, NASDAQ.com.
They're all available and you can actually
trade them.
So what was one of the suggestions
earlier?
When you've got a gross exposure of a
million dollars, and you see volatility
going through the roof, one of the
suggestions was you hedge.
A lot of people go and buy VIX in itself
to hedge their portfolio.
It's debatable whether you should do that,
simply because you're actually still
increasing your exposure.
So yeah, it might provide a hedge, but
you're locking yourself out of the party
to go and day trade.
You can just trade out of half your
positions, join the party to day trade and
then leave and build your portfolio back
and make money in between.
Whereas if you just bought a hedge, you'd
just be not losing as much money.
So it's debatable, but again it's
subjective to your own risk.
I can't tell you what to do, you have to
make your own mind up.
How do you calculate volatility for
currencies, commodities and bonds?
It's the same process and you're going to
get the spreadsheets.
So they'll be emailed to you next week.
Okay, welcome back.
I hope you managed to grasp some of the
concepts there with implied volatility in
the presentation.
Up to this point, we only looked at
historical volatility in the odds and
distribution calculation.
But the implied volatility is very
important because it not only shows us our
opportunities expected in the future,
but it also shows us our expected risk.
Because as a portfolio manager, which
you're going to be 80% of the time,
because we've already discovered from the
historical volatility that 80% of the
time,
there are no opportunities to be
short-term traders.
When you're a portfolio manager, it not
only shows you the opportunities in the
market expected,
it also shows you the implied risk of your
portfolio.
So those two things are really important.
And one of the things that retail traders
get wrong all the time in terms of
opportunities,
they tell the market that they are going
to trade in a particular way.
This is how I'm going to trade.
And no matter what, this is the way I'm
going to trade.
So they don't listen to the market and
what the market's telling them.
So in terms of opportunities, we learned
looking at historical volatility and now
implied volatility,
that's 80% of the time, there are no
short-term opportunities.
With the implied volatility situation, the
index is 80% of the time, the VIX below
25%.
And when you back that out, it just means
on a one-day basis,
that we're going to get the numbers
roughly that we saw in the historical
volatility calculation.
So that backs up everything that we saw in
the historical volatility calculations.
Now what does it mean in terms of market
opportunities for professional traders?
For professional traders, they just take
it as it is.
They allow the market to tell them what
the opportunities are.
And what the market tells you when you
look at the volatility index for the S&P
500,
is firstly that 80% of the time, there's
very few opportunities to make money on a
short-term basis.
Which means that you have to increase your
time horizon.
And all professional traders do this.
Professional traders are not what you'd
perceive.
They're not trading in and out in and out
every single minute of every day.
They're actually running long-short
portfolios on a one-to-three-month time
horizon.
Now let's focus on this statement that I
asked you to focus on.
That volatility is a trader's best friend
and a portfolio manager's worst enemy.
Now we looked at that example of the $1
million gross exposure portfolio.
And really we concluded that if volatility
moves up,
then the volatility on the risk of that
portfolio increases in line with the
volatility index.
So for example, if you're a portfolio
manager with a $1 million gross exposure,
and the volatility index doubles,
then all that occurs is that your $1
million yesterday becomes $2 million
today.
That's because the P&L swings within your
portfolio have now doubled.
So that's the caveat that we were
discussing.
The second caveat, which was that the
volatility index,
when it's called the fear index, is not a
fear of the volatility index going up and
therefore the market going down.
Because the definition of the volatility
index is that it can go up or down.
So that it's not called the fear index for
that reason.
The reason why it's called the fear index
is because professional traders are
predominantly portfolio managers
and they fear volatility itself because
it's their worst enemy.
Now what do they have to do?
Well, they have to transition.
When their risk goes up, they transition
from being portfolio managers into
short-term traders.
And in that process, they raise cash.
Or in trading accounts where margin is
utilized, they raise margin.
They have margin available, which enables
them to trade on a short-term basis.
So then they switch from being portfolio
managers to short-term traders.
And when volatility decreases, they switch
back from being short-term traders to
portfolio managers.
So they go from being one- to three-month
time horizon, long-short portfolio
managers, decreasing their exposure,
freeing up capital to enable them to trade
short-term.
And then switch back to becoming portfolio
managers when the market tells them that
they have to do it.
The way they interpret it is they take the
message that opportunities are increasing
on a short-term basis and your implied
risk of your portfolio is going up.
Therefore, you should transition from
being a portfolio manager to a short-term
trader.
And then the reverse, if the reverse is
true.
Now, the first caveat that we looked at
was this idea that there's some sort of
rulebook.
There isn't.
I've been teaching on the road now for two
years.
And one of the things that staggers me all
the time is that hands always go up in the
audience.
And people are always asking, so what do I
do in this situation?
What do I do in that situation?
Well, there's no rulebook.
You can't go to the bookstore.
You can't go on Amazon and buy a book
which says when the volatility index of
the assets that you're trading does this,
i.e. goes up 25% or drops 25%, you should
be doing exactly this.
It's a personal thing.
Because some people like trading
short-term.
Some people like being portfolio managers.
You don't have to transition from being a
portfolio manager to a short-term trader
or transition from a short-term trader to
a portfolio manager.
But you should definitely know, if you're
one or the other, the following.
If you're a portfolio manager and you see
the VIX going up, what's happening is your
risk is going up in line.
So if it goes up 50% and all your
positions are in S&P 500 stocks, your risk
has gone up 50% without you doing
anything.
That's the first thing if you're a
portfolio manager.
If you're only a short-term trader, well,
you should take the message from what
we've seen so far that 80% of the time
there are no short-term opportunities.
You should only trade when the
opportunities allow you to do so.
Because if you trade on a normal day in
the S&P 500 78% of times, the
opportunities don't exist.
And you're just going to lose money.
The problem is professional traders are
employed to make money all the time.
So they have to be portfolio managers in
one instance and transition and switch
into short-term traders and back again in
the other instance.
So when you're employed to make money all
the time, that's what you have to do.
You can't just non-participate.
However, for retail traders,
non-participation is obviously an option.
Now, I hope that you've picked up all
those messages because at least now you
know what the volatility index is.
We're going to move on now to Chris and
Chris is going to show you how you
calculate your own implied volatility
index from option prices as long as you
can get the data for any asset class.
So you can do it for indices, sector ETFs,
stocks within equities, commodities,
currencies, interest rates, bonds.
You can do this for anything as long as
you can get the data from the options
market.
Now, here's a little caveat for you as a
retail trader.
Because you're not trading high levels of
capital, this exercise is less important
for you.
What you're about to see in terms of the
spreadsheet work and the calculated
formulas, if you like, in the
spreadsheets, it's quite complicated, it's
quite mathematical.
But as a retail trader, you don't really
have to do this all the time.
You should just appreciate it and
understand it and know what it means when
the VIX goes up.
What we're about to show you is more
important if you're going to work at an
investment bank or you're going to work at
a hedge fund.
Because if you're going to go and work at
one of these places, you're going to be
expected to know this inside out.
Because you're trading very large levels
of capital, hundreds of millions of
dollars, and these measures become very
important.
But as a retail trader, really, you should
focus on the historical volatility of
distribution and odds calculation.
And what we're going to show you in video
number seven, which is the average true
range, which is the second historical
volatility calculation.
What I'm going to show you now is more
important if you're going to work at an
investment bank or a hedge fund.
But as a retail trader, just appreciate it
and know what you probably should be doing
if you're a portfolio manager and you see
volatility go up or go down.
And if you actually do get it, that's a
bonus.
But don't worry about it too much if you
find it a little bit too complicated.
Chris is now going to show you this in
video six and I'm going to see you back in
video seven and we're going to look at the
average true range.